[Music]
fbi special agent sean archer and his
son michael are on a father-son date
riding a carousel on a hill overlooking
the carousel is a sniper named caster
troy setting up his rifle to assassinate
the fbi agent the man is an
internationally wanted terrorist
responsible for hundreds of deaths and
acts of violence he waits some seconds
to get a clean shot before firing archer
is hit in the back and falls off the
ride alongside his son the bullet seems
to have gone through his body and struck
the innocent child in the head with
tears in his eyes the devastated father
crawls to his son while even castor is
stunned that he just killed a kid the
scene cuts to six years later archer has
been mourning his son's death and
looking for castor for the past six
years his madness to catch his son's
killer has affected his life in many
ways currently he has anointed his
fellow agents for failing to retrieve
information on caster's latest missions
somewhere else castor is posing as a
minister to sneak into the los angeles
convention center he hides in the back
to assemble an explosive called sinclair
meanwhile at the fbi office archer is
informed that caster's brother paulu has
just chartered a jet at a local airfield
knowing that paulu always flies with his
brother archer immediately orders an
undercover agent to be planted on the
plane at the same time his wife calls
him but archer ignores it driven by his
stubborn wish to put his work above all
paulu is at a local airfield with his
close friends leo and lars after waiting
impatiently for a while they are
relieved when caster arrives the
brothers then board the plane and are
greeted by winters an undercover agent
she does her job and informs the police
confirming that the terrorist is on
board soon after multiple police cars
and a helicopter approach the runway
caster isn't surprised to see archer and
his fellow agent tito chasing the
airplane to stop the terrorist from
retaliating winters points her gun at
caster but is in turn attacked and
knocked out by poyu an angered caster
kills winters in front of his rival
mocking him in the process in return
archer jumps into the helicopter and
rams it into the airplane caster sees
things going down and kills the pilot to
take control of the plane himself still
take off is impossible so the brothers
resort to firing at the police openly in
the following brawl poyu is captured but
caster ignores his brother's pleas and
runs to save his own life he then hides
in a nearby bunker while the police
split up to look for him a while later
he comes face to face with his biggest
enemy giving rise to another shootout
castor tries mocking him but his in turn
kicked into the backdraft of a turbine
he flies backwards falling unconscious
from the impact and is assumed dead in
the following scene archer returns home
to his wife eve and daughter jaime their
family is far from ideal because archer
has been too busy at work to be there
for them he can deal with international
terrorists but when it comes to his goth
daughter he's a lost cause the next day
archer is presented with paulu's disc
which contains information about their
next mission an animated woman comes up
on the screen saying how she is going to
blow everyone away on looking at the
schematics of sinclair archer registers
that it is a biological weapon one that
will end much of la killing thousands
the only way to get more info on the
explosive is through paulo but he would
only talk to his dead brother while
thinking of a way to get him to talk
archer's colleague miller takes him to a
private medical institution there archer
is met with a massive surprise as he
sees castor in a medically induced coma
on life support miller puts out her
cigarette on castor's skin proving that
he is fully captured she and the
institute's director dr walsh want
archer to take caster's face and voice
then go into erawan prison to extract
information from paulo the surgery will
be difficult but 100 effective these
guys would be a hit in florida the
doctor explains that the surgery is not
entirely permanent archer's height is
easy to correct his skin and eye color
are also close enough to casters to be a
reasonable match laser shears will help
make his hair more like casters and an
abdominoplasty will be done to rebuild
archer's body to resemble the terrorist
receding hairline bad abs good the most
important device for the procedure is a
morphogenic template that has an
exterior resembling castor's face archer
finds the plan nonsensical and starts to
leave while miller tries to convince him
otherwise at last he decides to try
interrogating known associates of
casters before eventually going forward
with the plan in the following scene
archer is seen torturing castor's
associates until they are on the brink
of death but still they do not talk he
also meets up with castor's girlfriend
sasha but she hasn't met him for two
years even her brother dietrich who
works as caster's supplier is
interrogated to no avail archer decides
to go through with the surgery but wants
to talk to director lazaro and his wife
before he makes a decision however he is
not allowed to do so because the mission
is classified and off the books which
means that no one else other than archer
and the two are allowed to know of it
until it is completed archer gives it a
thought realizes there are literally no
good reasons to agree and agrees then we
see him wishing farewell to his family
before going in for the surgery castor's
face is put on top of archer's exposed
muscles and connected which ends the
final procedure of the surgery a few
days later castor is on a hospital bed
with his head completely wrapped
meanwhile archer's bandages are
unwrapped and he sees himself as the
person he hates the most initially he
panics yelling [ __ ] you at everybody and
showing a deep hatred for himself
because of his face but tito and miller
calm him down quickly they soon place a
microchip in archer's larynx which
changes his voice entirely he has six
days until the bomb goes off to get
information from paul yu then archer is
let into erawan prison where he gets two
days to get poyu to talk the prison
warden walton welcomes him in calling
him the property of the prison his feet
are then clamped tight in magnetic boots
which allows the guards to monitor his
location and also look like they'd be
helpful on the moon after being led into
the cafeteria archer turns around to
talk to poyu when another inmate named
ivan attacks him he wants revenge on
castor ever since he slept with his wife
and sister at the same time sex
sandwiches are nick cage's favorite food
at the end of the fight archer's
magnetic boots are clamped to the em
field and the warden holds him back with
a gun meanwhile at the walsh institute
the real caster's heart rate begins
accelerating he miraculously stands
upright and even more miraculously isn't
tied down and soon realizes that his
face muscles are exposed in their gross
entirety the excruciating pain soon hits
him but he still manages to call lars
and leo for help the duo comes to his
aid in an instant and sets him free
using dr walsh as bait by now castor has
watched an entire documentary video on
the surgery and knows that it can be
reversed back in the prison archer gains
pull use trust and successfully manages
to extract information about the bomb he
is eager to talk to his associates but
to his surprise the next person to visit
him is caster himself he is wearing
archer's face having threatened the
doctor to perform the surgery the plan
has backfired and turned into a huge
disaster mostly because the mission is
off the records and if a select number
of people died archer could lose his
identity forever also those people did
die caster reveals that he has killed dr
walter and destroyed any evidence that
could be used to prove who he is an
enraged archer attacks him before the
guards rush in to stop him in the
following scene caster meets eve they
talk for a while before she leaves for
work as he stares at her ass then he
settles into archer's home and reads
eve's diary finding out that she and
archer haven't made love in two months
he also discovers jaime smoking in a
room and asks for her hidden stash jaime
calls him out for his strange behavior
before he leaves caster makes a deal
with his own brother and gets him out of
jail as a ruse when alone without any
cameras on them he reveals his true
identity and tells his brother to reveal
everything he knows to the police the
explosion is less important to caster
than making archer's life hell so he
chooses to be named a hero for revealing
where the explosive is kept as he had
planned he and a bomb squad rushed to
the convention center however the
explosive is protected by a pin which
will take hours to bypass in a dramatic
climax caster goes in instead of the
bomb squad for some reason and pulls the
correct pin stopping the explosion at
the last second he is praised by the
media and the news soon reaches archer
he feels suffocated unable to do
anything to save his family and
reputation in a desperate attempt to
flee he decides to break out of prison
he finds out that he can get his boots
taken off if he is given shock treatment
he starts a fight with a guard and is
taken to the clinic in the back on his
way he meets ivan and gets him on his
side by claiming he didn't sleep with
anyone from his family ivan helps archer
by attacking the guards and telling him
to run an epic shootout ensues causing
ivan to kill the guards in the control
room archer sits down at the computer
and overloads the security system just
when they think they have won the warden
kills ivan he wants to do the same to
caster but is surrounded by other
inmates who beat him to death death
archer thinks he's made good on his
escape before he realizes that the
prison is an oil platform in the ocean
before he can think of a way out a
helicopter appears making him jump off
the platform into the ocean after about
20 shots of him falling he doesn't
surface and the police assume that he is
dead caster is told about the incident
but he registers that archer is probably
alive and looking for him in the next
scene we see archer ending up at the
shore he calls eve but she doesn't
recognize him he gives it a thought
before deciding to drive to the
penthouse where castor's explosive
supplier diatrich lives he is welcomed
to a lively party of young people who
think that he is their companion
somewhere else caster sees jamie's
boyfriend dropping her off in front of
the house the [ __ ] boyfriend looking
like a member of some 41 tries to force
himself on her right in her own driveway
which predictably angers caster he beats
him up before sending him away and
having a long conversation with jaime
she trusts this terrorist wearing her
father's face more than she trusts her
father himself castor sees that she
hasn't gotten over her brother's death
yet and blames her father for everything
he hands her a knife teaching her how to
use it in case she is ever attacked back
at diatrich's penthouse archer wakes up
castor's girlfriend sasha making
advances at him he freaks out and tries
to send her away all while poyu watches
them from a roof across the street he
calls caster to tell him about the
incident meanwhile archer finds out that
sasha and castor have a son named adam
who caster never acknowledged she is
just a poor girl trying to make a living
for her child so that he can avoid a
criminal life archer sees his own son in
adam and hugs him accidentally blurting
his real son's name out in the process
on knowing archer's whereabouts caster
sends an fbi swat team to the penthouse
they fire a grenade launcher starting a
shootout between the two parties
archer's priority is to save sasha and
adam so he makes the kid wear a headset
muffling the noise of the gunshots the
shootout continues resulting in several
losses of life from both parties a while
later archer sasha adam and diatric find
each other caster discovers them and
aims his gun at archer his girlfriend
son and friend do not recognize him with
his face but he doesn't seem to care at
all he fires at sasha when she tries to
move but diatrich takes the bullet and
dies archer sees caster running and
follows him while firing several rounds
at him they stop for a second when
archer offers to exchange faces again
but caster refuses they look at
themselves in the mirror and then fire
through it at each other and there's
tons of symbolism archer is the first to
be hit by a bullet the two continue to
exchange fire until an fbi agent named
loomis arrives he makes archer run up
the stairway and sends caster diving for
cover poyu and archer face each other on
the roof and prepare to fight in the end
poyu falls down and dies poor poyu i
never even knew how to pronounce your
name caster sees his brother's dead body
and breaks into tears he loses his cool
and shoots loomis in the face the next
morning castor returns to his office
depressed by his brother's death the
director lazzaro comes in to critique
him for causing many unnecessary deaths
yesterday not caring about the cover
anymore caster tells lazaro his true
identity then knocks him to the ground
he also punches him in the heart and
stops it pretending that he just
suffered a fatal heart attack at the
same time archer breaks into his own
house and meets eve he calms her down
before telling her everything that
happened to him in the past month eve
does not believe him but he asks her to
check castor's blood type which is
different from his at night eve draws
some of castor's blood and drives over
to the hospital she soon comes face to
face with the truth when the blood
results match what archer told her
earlier just then archer comes into the
room eve draws a revolver on him but
once he tells her the story of how they
had their first kiss she realizes the
truth suddenly caster arrives with leo
and lars looking for archer having found
out that eve knows the truth eve quickly
pretends to be attending to a burn
patient and makes up a story about being
on call for the night caster accepts her
story and sends his men away but once
alone we find out that he knows eve is
lying the next day sasha and archer go
to lazzaro's funeral where caster is
holding eve and jaime hostage sasha
hands archer a gun asking him to avenge
her brother's death a gunfight ensues
and all of caster's minions are killed
including sasha but don't worry no doves
were harmed in the making of this scene
caster and archer engage in a battle
when jaime finds a gun and shoots at
archer believing him to be the real
caster she soon realizes her mistake
when caster takes her as his hostage and
licks her face game of thrones did not
invent incest after all he then makes
his escape and ends up on a boat while
being followed by archer after a lengthy
chase which is one of the craziest most
expensive scenes i've ever seen in a
movie and you should see it too both
archer and caster's boats are destroyed
in a final showdown archer hits up a
famous moment of cage rage and then
kills castor with a harpoon with his
dying breath the terrorist destroys his
own face to prevent archer from
reclaiming it when everything calms down
eve explains the situation to the fbi
and convinces them of archer's true
identity archer goes through surgery and
his face is restored he also has the
bullet wound from the beginning finally
removed because this doctor is a miracle
worker having finally moved on from the
death of his son in the final scene
archer brings sasha's son adam into the
family without asking his wife if she's
okay with it and they raise him as their
own
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching